this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised this is why the inclement ride
is such a firm favorite
[Music]
it just looks ready for a fight
this is still her territory
[Music]
how insane was that good afternoon
what a way to start the twelfth episode
of Safari lives that there is a Chava
the female leopard will tell you a
little bit about the Contra poem she had
like that Sebastian they want her home
she had this morning with her mother is
it was with her mother and with her
consort Sebastian jambe is on camera
that's what I was talking to in case you
thought I was talking to no one in
particular please talk to us over the
course of this next highlights package
show two hours of action-packed
highlights from the Masai Mara in Kenya
and of course of the sabi sands here in
South Africa and of course also some
live action what we have over there like
I said is go Java the female leopard she
who is afraid apparently is what it
means we're going to go around to the
other side at some stage and enjoy her
you'll enjoy her face rather than just
the back of her head like I said please
talk to us using hashtags fire live on
Twitter otherwise you can talk to us
using the chat stream on YouTube any of
your questions or comments would be
hugely appreciated Tristan is going to
unpack what happened around this area
this morning quite an astonishing thing
there basically all of our cat
characters of Jummah was set underneath
the same tree in the same sighting so
that was very special we'll get some
updates from Amara as I said we've had
the Lions obviously they've been
knocking about the place cheetah as well
and the inimitable Northtown of hyena
also over here the main feature of
course has been ting Ghana the male
leopard we've seen him I think just
about every single day this week so
there's lots to have a look at over the
course of the next two hours and it's
wonderful to have you with us here it
began for me with 10 Ghana in the
morning light
the Duke has had a busy week in the
eastern section of his territory his
forays have been an exercise in forensic
foraging who might say scavenging but
this word has a negative connotation
implying the brutish theft of another
predators meals kangana's efforts were a
severe test of Leopard olfactory skills
his sharp nose twice led him to kills
made by a pack of two female wild dogs
in this case the remains of an Impala
which he stashed in a picturesque
tambuti Grove so that was the purse
first pet purse first part of king
Ghana's busy week here we are a little
bit closer now to kochava we haven't got
quite dry on the other side we will do
so in due course but she not magnificent
this is the quintessential African
leopard shot let's keep going a little
bit Patrick you say you love good Chava
I think we all do and I think we all
would rather spend a lot more time with
her than we manage at the moment the
only reason we don't spend more time
with her because she spends the bulk of
her time to the south and east of where
we are that's south and east of Jummah
Patrick we don't know where the cub is
but the cub is old enough not to be in
any danger
in other words she'll be stashed away
safely somewhere and it's not unusual
for this leopard to be spending a little
bit of time away from her cub
let's just move into this little spot
here and you'll get an amazing view
oh now naturally she's turned her head
the other way there we go
please don't look that way my dear I
mean that probably is the best way for
the light but I've chosen did now
possibly should have stayed exactly
where we were where we're going to try
and convince her to turn her head this
way
in the meantime Tristan has been unable
to cope with all of the action here this
morning and so he has taken to sitting
on the floor indeed James this morning
was just too much and so I've decided
that I can't mobilize either on my feet
or in a vehicle inside decided to sit on
the floor and to just enjoy the
afternoon and take it very very easy no
we're not on the floor for that reason
we're on the floor because we have a
situation where we are trying to find
little Columbus from this morning so we
were here early this morning we managed
to find him and have a really good
sighting of her but we're trying now
just to see if we can find some tracks
and just try and see exactly where she's
gone we found one little track and it's
really tough here because her foot is
very very small and so if I put my hands
next to it you might not even be able to
see this track but at the back here
we've got this kind of little three
loads pad and in these tiny little toes
that are over there so it is very very
very my Newton on the sort of hardest
ground it's quite difficult to actually
see where she's walked so we've come to
where I had her last and this was the
track that she went to before she laid
down and kind of curled up into a little
ball when we lift her so this is kind of
our starting point and this is where
we'll try and see if we can find little
amber this afternoon now the thing is
with her is that she was a little bit
skinny this morning and she was kind of
hoping to find some food and hoping for
mom to come back and hopefully bring her
something so she's going to be probably
still somewhere in this area unless tiny
did return and then in which case we'll
hopefully find Tandy's tracks but while
we search and we try and see if we can
find our little character that is moving
about up in the Mara Jamie's been having
a lot more of a good time than what we
have
last week we were witness to the
somewhat distressing scene of the happy
zebra hyena clan catching and killing a
baby buffalo from this exact heard
something that they have become
specialists in in the valleys around the
Salt Lick before they could finish their
hard-earned meal the sausage tree pride
of lions came in and stole it from them
now that seems to be something that
would be considered quite unusual nobody
really expects lions to steal from
hyenas but that is what they do very
regularly particularly if their male
lions involved unfortunately for the
away no pride they didn't have any males
with them when they called their Buffalo
meal of the week a new day dawned bright
and clear in the Maasai Mara and the O
Widow pride were finally successful in
their quest for a meal the hunting skill
of the formidable females ensured that
all bellies were filled to bursting
point as Mike fell the smell of the
buffalo attracted unwanted attention and
eerie rallying cries turned the meal
into a battleground between two forces
of nature
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
the a winner prides second attempt to
reclaim lost ground was made by
penetrable defense of mine of teeth
[Music]
I'm numbered and at risk of serious
injury the Lions were forced to
surrender and within minutes the
hysterical cackles calmed and the
victorious hyena made short work of the
spoils of war an unlucky night afore the
oh we no pride but perhaps not as
unlucky as the poor hapless Buffalo that
was devoured the interesting thing about
that particular sighting was it was
around about 300 or 400 meters from the
North Klan den site that's actually why
Tristan and myself sat out there because
it was very much a team work based
sighting Tristan was there the entire
day we joined him a little bit later the
reason that we did that was because we
assumed that North clown would come in
and be the ones to steal from the or we
know as only when I went back and looked
through the footage later that I
realized at the error of that assumption
because it was not North Klan it was the
happies a Brooklyn
how that happened what they were doing
there probably close on 25 kilometers
away from the centre of their territory
I have absolutely no idea could it be
that the happy zebra clan have tired of
hunting this herd of buffalo and are in
search of greener pastures well wasn't
that just absolutely amazing Jamie had
an incredible sighting and actually
funny enough I was in that same sighting
with her when I was up in the Mara in
the beginning of the week and it was
really quite something to watch this
sort of a winner of pride and the sort
of hyenas coming in and trying to chase
these lines off the kill not trying they
successfully tried to do it and did it
and took the meal it was really quite
something to watch the interesting thing
about it is we sat there for the whole
day so we were there about I would say
probably about 16 hours when before the
hyenas arrived and when we got there you
know there was nothing really happening
and late into the night we still hadn't
seen much one high in a tried to be
brave and came in early in the sort of
afternoon it was very quickly sort of
vanquished by the Lions and then you
know we're about to actually need the
sighting and as I drove out onto the
road all of these eyes just appeared
down the road and it was about sort of a
tie inners and we thought well this is
going to be the start of it and I ain't
his wind towards the carcass and he
actually three broke off towards the
carcass and then what we had was
the most incredible thing is all of a
sudden one vocalization and there was
twenty hyenas where they came from we
have no idea we could not see them at
all
prior to that they all kind of just
stood out over the grass and then rushed
in and kind of chased off their win your
pride now scenic you were saying you
don't know much about the win your pride
and where do they come from and do we
know anything about them well the winner
pride is basically what we used to call
the little sausage tree pride so there
is break off from the sausage few pride
and are sort of part of that but what we
think is that when they had their Cubs
which some of you may remember from last
year it was the the set of Cubs that had
their very pale individual in there they
might have had their cubs with different
males to what the sausage big sausage
free pod has had and so therefore it's
meant that the females have the kind of
split off and had to go off on their own
to take their cubs to keep them safe we
also know that kinky tail was part of
attacking those little babies that were
at one point and so maybe the females
just thought well we're going to be
threatened by this big part we're gonna
break off front our own and so two
females left with their three offspring
and that's what the Irwin your pride has
become now the reason they called the
Irwin your pride and not the little
sausages is because it gets very
confusing when you start to have a
situation where you've got sausage tree
pride little sausage tree pride and no
one really knows what's going on and
they spend a lot of their time in an
area that's called the winnow tree plain
and so basically it's right up against
the escarpment and it kind of goes
towards this road that we call the
escarpment road and it runs sort of from
south of n gamma all the way down
throughout the 50-kilometer sign and
they spend most of their time there and
they like to actually often climb in a
window trees and so it seems like an
appropriate name for them and it's a
kind of works art in the way that you
you just sort of know where they are and
what the sort of pride composition is so
that's the little bit of this sort of
backstory they're an incredible group of
lionesses for me they're one of the sort
of prized that I've really enjoyed
spending time with and I'll tell you why
it's because two of them to bring down
big adult Buffalo like they do is
absolutely insane it for me it's an
amazing thing to see two lionesses
bringing our Buffalo we know it's a very
difficult thing and if the reason why
they're able to do it is because both of
those females are large individuals the
one is seriously muscular and the other
one is built a bit like a male she's
very very big she's much bigger than any
of the other lines
while I was in the Mara so they're
interesting kind of pride and they
certainly have found themselves in a
great place to be able to find Buffalo
and all kinds of other things and they
certainly going to be a big part of the
next sort of a few years and hopefully
around the taina din will the North
Canton there's going to be a lot of sort
of interaction there because of where
they are good we're going to carry on
we're going to try and track Colombo who
tracks head off in this direction while
we do that we're going to send you
across to big biceps Byron so he can say
good afternoon to all of you good
afternoon you're all having a wonderful
day so far my name is Byron and when
camera with me this afternoon is Craig
now it's amazing James has been very
fortunate he's found that female leopard
now we are in search of some other
animals in this area and I think I have
just seen a poor in the grass give us a
second stay with us this is really
exciting let's have a look let's have a
look now the grass if you have a look
and scan that's very very thick and what
I caught a glimpse of I can actually see
it there now watch out Craig of these
branches can you get that have a look at
there you can just see and rather large
Paul look at that I'm gonna move a bit
closer let's get a better view and see
exactly what it is I have got a feeling
it's a male lions
now it's quite thick through here a
little bit of a drainage line oh this is
gonna be difficult
hold on this is the tough parts of
getting closer to these animals but
don't worry we've got a good vehicle I
think so let's see
hold on
Wow that's a male line there's at least
two I think three these are the vodka
males wonderful wonderful I have not
seen them before this is the first time
I get to see these male lions
that's great I will definitely try to
get better views of them but for now you
can see they're on line down there out
in the open fortunately they're not
right at the base of a thicket or or
under tree now our tuned open but the
grass is fairly long around them how
wonderful is that that's a great fun
that's awesome I'm so glad we found them
alright I'm going to try getting to a
better position to view these lines but
while I do that let's quickly go back to
the dark maned male Tristan well Bayon I
feel like you you and you're sort of
heritage will have a much darker Mane
then I would although mine is quite
darker I feel like there's a lot of gray
hairs creeping in at these space and so
that's not ideal at all
but anyway besides that thanks for
carrying on the tracks we're still
trying to kind of work out what's going
on we actually did find a track to sow
it looks like maybe their technique
actually came back at some point during
the day might have fetched Columbus so
we're gonna just check it out and make
100% sure try find a little bit more of
an open area you can see here there's
quite a lot of grass cover which makes
it very very difficult and it makes it
hard to find so we'll just try and find
a bear patch which we call that kind of
a track trap and I and see if we can
find those tracks over there now this
morning when we were trying to kind of
be art and we were testing the drone we
were trying to sort of find any sign of
any animal whatsoever and we were lucky
enough able to hear some in parlors and
in parlors actually led us to the very
cat that we're trying to find now
beautiful Columbus it's posing atop a
small termite mound her piercing gaze
watching her every move
soon she grows bored of us and begins to
move off should be free times a small
broken love and stares into the distance
she has spotted something and suddenly
moves forward carefully placing each
foot in front of the other to our
surprise a big great giant appears from
the thickets its short trunk in her herd
they begin feeding as they pass by
Columba you are completely disinterested
finds herself a cozy patch you know it's
erased for the rest of the day well this
is the exact spot that we managed to
find her this morning so she was sitting
atop this mound kind of being as cute as
could be she really is an amazing little
leopard I've thoroughly enjoyed seeing
her this morning I was absolutely blown
away at just how big she's gotten the
last time I saw her she must have been
at least half the size of what she is
now now she's starting to look like a
real leopard and not this sort of a
cubby kind of character that we were
seeing a few months ago she's also full
doubts at all that she's no longer as
wiry I find leopard cubs when they swim
hit that force is sort of an 8-month
phase they often their legs are quite
long they quite narrow they don't really
have that sort of bulky lipid feel to
them that an adult has got so she's
pulled out a lot more she's starting to
look a lot more like a proper lipid now
and I'm sure she's going to provide us
with many many sightings to come now
what I was saying earlier today that I'm
pretty sure she will be in this area
unless sandy comes back to feature now
this morning Sydney was out and about he
had an absolutely insane morning and he
managed to bump into Tandy and I'm
pretty sure if Tandy's come back we know
the reason why
and alert Andi sits motionless in the
long grass her gaze focused in ears
twitching just spotted something that
all difference fear most'
Lyons it's the apocalypse and they've
seen 20 to both freezes the time stands
still each camp weighing up into next
move move 10 years the first one to
break and she runs thankfully though the
ibaka seemed disinterested and fell out
on you to slink away into the thick bush
one male however keeps an eye out and
after a few sniffs of the breeze is up
dragging his coalition members with him
as he follows his nose in the direction
of wait 10 disappeared
[Music]
well as you can see tanya was incredibly
lucky and I am absolutely surprised
after watching some of the footage that
those lines did not move I would have
thought if those three males had been
close to tell you that they were
definitely going to try and chase her
and I know many other lines that are in
this area including the Birmingham boys
and in Kakuma pride most definitely
would have had they got that close -
Tandy says she got away likely this
morning and she was really very very
fortunate in that those boys just didn't
seem to be interested and so I wonder
why I mean I know we know the boys walk
quite far yesterday and I and know that
because somebody actually saw them in
money later yesterday morning and
actually watched them then cross back
into Manya later yesterday afternoon
from Buffalo and then they came all the
way back down to the southern parts of
Juma so they walked quite a long way
yesterday but normally with lions when
they come across another leopard they
find a situation where they all sort of
not another leopard a leopard they'll
chase it and they insist this sort of
competition that they have with other
cats that they try to kind of you know
get rid of them and sort of chase them
away so it's very surprised that she was
able to kind of get out of then I'm sure
she breathed a sigh of relief albeit a
very momentarily sort of moment she
would has got herself into a little bit
of a tangle a little bit later now I
believe James Henry is sitting with well
not the offspring that we're looking for
but one of Tani's others
well yes one of Kunduz offspring indeed
there we have kochava still sitting on
her bow we've gone around the street 386
times because she keeps moving his head
from side to side as soon as she
realizes there's a lens on her she turns
her head the other day other way so
we've quite cunningly positioned a whole
vehicle full of guests the other side of
the tree and so she now has no choice
but to look into a lens wherever she is
I of course joking I don't think she
notices where the vessel ends faced her
way or not she does keep looking down
towards the western side and we're
wondering perhaps one of those other
leopards aren't around no never too late
let me assure you that this cat would
not be in the tree if she thought she'd
fall out of it when she fell asleep they
definitely do sleep soundly in trees
especially with their legs either side
of the bow like that but often they just
doze so I don't think she's been in a
particularly deep sleep while we've been
here I think she has been dozing for
most of the time and you know even if
she does fall asleep she'd wake up
before she kind of fell out otherwise
they wouldn't have developed this
ability or this sort of desire to be in
trees and the reason she's up there of
course is because she's safe now she's
safe from the Lions which are not far
from here at all Byron I think has just
found them he may be just still trying
to get into a position but they're not
far from here
Tandi and ting ghana must be around here
somewhere as well she keeps looking down
to the west I wonder if she's looking at
the Lions or she's looking at Tandy and
ting Ghana but really there has been the
most utterly astounding day today and
let's go across to Tristan now so that
he can unpack what happened indeed we do
need to unpack what happened but before
we do that we have a little crime scene
that we've managed to stumble across and
it's an interesting one because I was
talking about this morning with Columbia
and the fact that she'll often hunt
little birds at her age and we'll try
and kind of go after birds to find
small meals and this sort of feather
pattern that we see here that's all kind
of distributed art could very well have
been a kill that she might have made the
thing is about this is when you have
sort of feathers that are tightly packed
the way that these are so you can see
all the feathers are in a very very
close proximity to them to where that
the sort of kill must have happened
they haven't drifted her away and that
means that whatever ate it ate sit on
the ground if this had been something
like a bird of prey that had been in a
tree you would have found as it plucks
the feathers you know feathers obviously
being very light and designed to catch
wind catch wind and they spread over a
big distance and so you have a situation
where you'll find feathers kind of
scattered all around where we are now
these are all confined to a very small
space so and I wonder if maybe for
lumber I didn't have a little sort of
kill at some point in the last few days
and it was a dove or something that was
killed in this particular area it's
pretty interesting to see and these are
the kind of signs that you look for when
you're tracking through thicker grass
areas you can't always see their
footprints but you can sometimes find
little signs like this to indicate where
they've gone and where they've been now
James is saying that we had an insane
morning stuck as we finished our drive
this morning we were on our way home
before absolute pandemonium broke out
down in the south as if Tandy's morning
could not get any worse after running
into the Ibaka boys there is now an
intruder in her kingdom to deal with the
to move swiftly side by side through the
thickets they break cover we can see a
sketch of a tan his first daughter she
tries to run from your mother but Andy
is not in the mood and is not to prove
that her daughter is no longer welcome
in her territory
tiny launchers at the java small scuffle
ensues both then start to try to
side-by-side sizing one another
suddenly they both left would show a
turn of speed and begin to rank
the reason becomes obvious is their
[ __ ] boys into the fray once again
each other wastes no time in a sense hi
inside not falling for safety but
unbelievably there's a twist in this
tale yet again I have know it in Ghana
the Duke arrives on the scene very in
search of the lipids causing the stir in
his area and tests they're picking up
the females scent before sitting down to
risk his wrist is short-lived as once
again the Ibaka voice arrived and show
you this the real king of whooping cats
each other safety pushing the tree
watches is wasted on entanglement in
narrow escape
well how incredible is that sighting and
how lucky have all of our cats been to
actually be able to get out of that I
think Tandy Tenggara and kochava can
count themselves very very fortunate
that they didn't get themselves into a
massive brawl that resulted in them not
paying attention and not seeing those
lines I think they were very lucky that
they kind of had a little scuffle and
kind of broke apart and were able to see
the lines coming but absolutely be
insane three lipids and three male lines
in the same sighting is unheard of and
Sidney who was actually in the sizing
must have had the most ridiculous
morning because you know he's arrived in
the sabi sands taken a game drive bumped
into a lipid which bumped into lions
then stayed with the Lions went back to
another lipid and then there wasn't a
three well two other lipids arrived they
had a big scuffle and male lines arrived
this is just a fairy tales kind of start
a tough time sort of following that up
but what was really interesting to me in
that whole sighting was the way timely
reacted to kochava you could clearly see
when they were running kochava was the
individual that was closest to the
camera and tiny was in the background
and you can see a squid Chavez sort of
peels away and starts to try and get
away from tandy she comes flying from
this direction and she's the one that's
actually the aggressor that jumps Attica
Java and they scuffle and then you know
roll in the ground she's actually trying
to hit them it's pretty clear to me that
tiny even though she's sort of a slight
female and she's not the biggest she
packs a serious punch it's the second
time I've seen it fight it's sort of a
similar time last year but a month away
from when she sort of fought with some
Gila and it's the same situation is that
she was not afraid in any way whatsoever
to dive in there and to go after
whatever female she deemed was a threat
to her territory into her cubs and it's
a reason why she's been such a good
mother and why she's been able to keep
Kalama is safe from all these marauding
males as well as even females that have
come into this area the interesting
interesting part about it was ting ganas
response he kind of came into the area
but once he figured out there was two
females he settled right down you can
see he started to relax he started to
lie down he was just watching those two
females just trying to see exactly what
they were doing and he wasn't too fussed
once he realized that I think initially
you would have found he probably heard
fighting of lipids and to him it must
have been maybe these males around he
needs to go check this out and he moved
verify he went away from the dam this
morning and kind of ran that way and you
could see was actually panting at one
point trying to catch his breath from
being sort of moving so fast trying to
catch up with everything so it was
really an insane sighting now alley it
was amazing to have all of this in one
morning was just incredible if you think
in total we had four different lipids
three male lions herds of elephants it
was just absolutely insane everything
was kind of happening and everything was
interacting with each other and that's
one amazing thing about tumor is that
the interaction between species as well
as between the characters that we follow
is really quite something
so probably the sabi sands is one of the
best places for interaction like this
and to be able to see interspecies sort
of relationships and those kind of
things so it was an insane morning and
one that's I doubt any one of us will
forget and the best thing about it is
that because it was so insane if we had
met nobody got hurt
it made it just that much better so the
fact is nobody is injured nobody it was
sort of lost their life and for us then
you know that's the sort of base
scenario that could have played out from
a very difficult scene good well we're
gonna keep trying to track down save the
grace of Lady in the form of Tandy and
Columbia and see where they've gotten in
the meantime though we're going to send
you I think across to Byron and see what
he's been up to and whether he's had any
success this afternoon
yep we've just repositioned and we are
still sitting with these beautiful male
lines there's a little bit of movement
but they still seem quite relaxed and
resting now
it is a cooler afternoon so I wouldn't
be surprised if these males decide to
get up and start moving a lot earlier
than usual because of the cooler
temperatures so that's what I'm hoping
for
I'm going to be very very patient and
sit with him I would love to see these
males get up and move around but this is
awesome and exactly as Justin was saying
what an exciting morning all this um all
this action action-packed morning Kali
you are very happy to see the focus now
it's always wonderful having male lions
moving about so it is great to see these
males the last coalition of three but
interesting that behavior of the
leopards a quick little fight and then
obviously these Lions coming through and
the leopards getting out of there as
soon as possible
up into trees and just running away I
mean they do not want to be surprised by
these males these males would kill a
leopard if they did come across it
purely because it's competition
now these lines are the ones that are
responsible for chasing that leopard
that female leopard could chava
up into the tree that James has got
let's go find out if it's still up there
well it is still here of course but I
think it was probably also its mother
that put her up in the tree like this
certainly she's had a day to remember
and I suspect you will slink off to the
South sometime this evening hopefully
back to her safe cub we heard that the
cub is safe no reason she shouldn't be
well he shouldn't be as a little male
and she's probably just going to wait
for the cover of darkness before she
disappears
it looks pretty well fed so I think
she's particularly in need of a meal
I think that these female leopards who
are in each other's terror territories
or you know when they come across a
territorial boundary like happened this
morning us what's happened between Tandy
and kochava I think they all find that
there is a relative aggression but
because I know each other they're not
actually hugely aggressive with each
other and I really don't think that
kochava would necessarily set upon
calamba should there be a meeting
between the two I think Colombo would
run and really make an effort to get
away very quickly and I don't think that
kochava would make the effort to push
through on that sort of attack so that's
from I'm sorry I'm missing this name
here Bros Cooper is what I can hear is
that correct no scooper no scooper well
that's a very interesting name
no scooper so no in short I do not
believe that kochava would cause Columba
any harm
especially if tangia was around this
whole incident this morning is kind of a
I think a a random not a random but a
whole lot of serendipity if you like
I think kochava and Tandy happened upon
the southern boundary of Tandy's
territory and the East the western
boundary would north western boundary of
coach Ava's territory there happened to
be there on at the same time they met up
the noise that they made growling at
each other and in fact having physical
contact which I say is quite unusual and
probably possibly not unsurprisingly
initiated by Tandy it seems that would
have attracted to the lions to come and
see what was going on and it would have
done exactly the same fort in Ghana so I
think that the noise that these two
ladies made is what attracted ting Ghana
into the area and definitely what
attracted the Lions I don't think they
were particularly interested obviously
they would kill these leopards if they
could get hold of them but they
certainly doesn't make an enormous
effort I've seen lions climb trees after
lipids before so you know while they're
nowhere near as adept as
leopards in trees and the livers would
almost certainly have escaped if the
Lions had truly wanted to push home some
kind of attack they would easily have
climbed up a tree in order to certainly
harass them a little bit further so
that's what spotting over here
everything seems fairly calm ting Ghana
down possibly towards twin dams possibly
where this leopard is looking but I'm
not really sure
well sky I think if you're a human being
and your mother I started to hiss and
growl at you'd be deeply confusing and
unsettling but of course this is normal
with leopards is what they do and it's
how they operate it's how they've always
operated and so as much as it might seem
unpleasant that tandy is hissing and
snarling at her daughter their daughter
doesn't want to be around her mother
either
so go Chavo wolf is not it's not like a
child was trying to come into this area
and say hi to mum will come home in some
way she's marking her territory she's
trying to perhaps push her Northwest and
boundary out slightly and that's got her
into trouble today now the only leopard
we haven't well we haven't managed to
find a number of leopards today by
ourselves they've certainly arrived in
our sightings but ting Ghana has been
the main feature of the week as I said
and his second great incident occurred
the afternoon after his Impala thieving
with the carcass stashed safely in the
shade taganas afternoon began will
enough as he ages so he likes to spend
extended periods resting his eyelids in
the winter Sun but the original owners
of the parlor arrived as dusk fell most
likely on the hunt for something fresh
but as everyone knows nothing quite gets
up the nose of a dog like the smell of a
cat the old Duke senses have not dulled
and once in the bowels of his tank were
tea tree he casts the stain for glances
of the droning of g-rated so that was
just a very sort of I think almost
nonchalant approach to the whole
experience biting Gardner he's such a
wily old fellow he heard those things
coming from a long way off he judged the
distance between himself the tree and
the dogs to perfection just trotted up
into the bars of the tree knew they
couldn't get there put his head down
he didn't growl at them once he didn't
hiss at them once he just kind of lay
there and glared at them while they
hopped up and down below the tree in a
state of deep anguish it was very funny
and I don't know if you could hear them
making the noise in that clip but they
made the most amusing sort of angry
irritated howling bark and kangana cared
not one jot at all so that was very
special
now finally Ralph Kerstin who's in his
first Safari lives for the last little
while has developed some signal and he'd
like to say hello
well thank you James and hello everybody
and welcome here to the ajumma excuse me
the chit wa waterhole just in front of
chitwa chitwa and lodge and you can see
actually just from those hippos there
they're all sitting out of the water
because it's rather cold and well
they've all escaped out of that called
on to the bank trying to get themselves
a little bit warmer and well they're all
being rather noisy and some of them are
all sitting with those those oxpeckers
we can actually hear them quite nicely
now and every now and then they all fly
up and make a lot of chattering noise
and we can hear the hippos here once
again and you can see actually by the
poo that is on those hippos that they've
been out of the water for a large period
of the day already and that just shows
that this cold front that has moved in
has mattered rather uncomfortable for
them in the water but at least we get to
see those hippos out of the water and
thank you all the viewers for saying
welcome back it has been a wonderful
vacation that I had done in the Eastern
Cape where I am from but I'm really
enjoying being back this morning was my
first little walk and now being here on
chesa and really loving to be in the
presence of these big animals once more
so but well it seems like the weather
has followed me because it came up from
Cape Town and it hit us in the Eastern
Cape and then come all the way up with
us here now our lorem were you say
that's quite a cuddle of hippos well I
would definitely not be very comfortable
going and cuddling one of them but they
do look very cuddly don't they and look
at that little youngster being a little
bit naughty I'm sure as youngsters are
I've got two little boys of my own and I
know that they're always looking or up
to nonsense but it's always good
and look at that little baby he's he's
um he's grown quite a bit actually now
the cold does bother the hippos a little
but as you can see here it does drive
them to to move accordingly now that's
half the reason why they they do go into
the water because they're not very good
at regulating their own temperature they
sort of need the water for that
thermoregulation and it's normally too
hot for them out of the water in the hot
Sun but when it's cold like this
obviously the water is also very cold
and so they then come out of the water
to to get a bit of warmth I would say
because normally they only exit the
water to go out and feed and they spend
most of the day in the water frolicking
and and snoozing actually because
they're pretty much nocturnal when it's
very hot and they come out at night to
graze and well it looks like these two
are braving the cold now all about cold
because I do a lot of surfing myself and
but I do do it with a wetsuit on I'm not
privileged enough to live near warm
waters like these guys at the moment I'm
sure they would they would quite like to
have a wetsuit to a neoprene bodysuit
because that would really help them in
this kind of weather and so it's a
wonderful to sit in the presence of
these big animals as I've said and it
seems like it's been an absolutely
amazing week with all the big cats but
well it's not just been an amazing week
it's an amazing day
which is an amazing day but for the
light which has failed us now completely
when we arrived here she was bathed in
perfection now it's really got a little
grim above her still we're sitting with
the latest how could we complain el we
simply could not and it's a leopardus
that we do not see very often at all she
is most often South and often east of us
so it's very very pleasant to have her
here with us it would be very nice of
her little male cub was in the same
place that we won't be fussy especially
after what we saw this morning so if you
are a new viewer let's just quickly
unpack the little hierarchy on a
hierarchy family tree of leopards that
we have been showing you in those trips
basically we have got tündi who is the
new queen of Jummah a nylon 13 year old
Lepidus coming to the twilight of their
years if you like she's got a cup called
Columba who's now 8 months old this is
her daughter who Chava who if I'm not
mistaken is about who Chavez not much
more than 4 I don't think I keep
forgetting the ages of these animals and
kochava has a young cub as well and that
took up what we think is probably about
6 months old at the stage I think she
was born here about 6 months old he's
it's a male so that's the females of our
particular patch then we have Tigana the
aging duke of Jummah he is now 13 years
old as well and he's looks after the
territory that they to reside him he's
been pushed to the limits of light by a
chap called ho Kimura he an intimidating
short but very stocky leopard who's come
in from we don't know where he's been
spotted all over parts of the southern
kruger on his way up to setting a
territory now to the west of where Tim
Ghana
calls himself at home into his territory
has come another female after the demise
of Tandy's sister shadow her name is Shu
do Lu which is
tremendously wonderfully romantic name
it means termite mound she is also a
very appealing looking leopard and if
you were to see them together the
slipper dancer Dooley you would
immediately notice the different senses
again of course if you are a new viewer
must for regular viewers can spot these
leopards and identify them from about
you possibly one spot and should do no
muscling in on the western side of
Tandy's territory so those the main
leopard characters that we are looking
at at the moment and there's a little
bit of conflict I suppose but things are
settling down quite nicely now but from
time to time has happened this morning
so the conflict will brew up again and
attract the attentions of a whole lot of
other predators all right Lee let's go
back and have a look now at what ting
gana got up to as the morning after his
Impala for two mornings after his Impala
for a
two days after the great Impaler
investigation the same two female dogs
made another large kill that they were
unable to finish satiated they lift the
carcass of the adult Bush back Ram and
disappeared there was much debate over
which scavenger would grab the one
afternoon bizarrely and with a large
audience waiting next to the now
disemboweled bush buck to garner lost
the scent and lay down to the truss I
even tried to point out to him as he
paid no I'm not sure if you could see
what I was trying to do there but the
reason the aerials in the shot metal
there's poles and things was because we
were parked in front of that carcass
waiting for him to walk up to it because
up until about 10 meters before he got
there he was on a beeline straight forth
and suddenly he turned to the left and
there were three vehicles waiting for
him to snatch up the carcass and drag it
into a tree but unfortunately he lost
the wound somehow I was trying
desperately to point it out to him but
he paid no heed and eventually after 20
minutes or so we had to leave him
eventually however he did find it
eventually ting gana must have found the
bush bucket and dragged it into a
picturesque Bush willow tree overlooking
a dry riverbed the scraggly and spikey
branches were clearly not particularly
comfortable and he had to try endless
positions before setting in through a
snooze with a ready-made meal to last
him the rest of the day the old coot was
satisfied with the week's work well done
so that was his experience with the woof
buckle and very nice that he managed to
find it and he then fed on that kill for
two and a half days it really is quite
impressive
that he managed to eke out sort of not a
living but he eats out meals from that
half-eaten bush buck for that length of
time the hyenas came in they spent a lot
of time waiting for him here we go
leopard coming Tiny's in Tunney's in my
goodness gracious me
that's the mother that's Tandy
this is unbelievable stuff everybody
let's see if she goes up she's marking
her territory now I don't think she's
gonna try and get up that tree but she
might let's just wait and see what
happens here this is unbelievable stuff
we've wondered where she was we've said
she was possibly off towards the west
but here she is now so that all right on
a territorial boundary as I say of
course they won't tolerate each other
like I say but I don't think it will be
really as violent as it might be were
they're not related he said he saw Tandy
war shadow and Karuna who were mother
and daughter interacting a few times
together on their territorial boundary
used to blow spit bubbles at each other
was just for funny
miss magic dragon was it absolutely here
we go girl affection and all she's doing
now is marking her territory making sure
making very sure that she do not show
you
let's go Chava knows who has passed us a
lot of hissing and growling going on
here
but we don't want to do also is get
caught up in some kind of or what they
call not misplaced aggression what's it
called deferred aggression I'm using the
wrong word so things do get really quite
heavy was tündi who is known not to like
her vehicles too much you might just
back off slightly
Nadine Tandy in my opinion is the least
funny leopard in all of the sabi sands
she is no comedian at all I don't wish
to have her as close to me is it nice
and still Sebastian
we're just gonna sit very quietly here
Paul I don't know if Tandy knows that
sir daughter I'm 90% sure she does but
she seen his arrival now she's not seen
as a daughter
so nice and slow
she's in front of us she is
all of this is marking territory she's
got an angry face
he always has had not a fringe a kitty
whoo that was quite exciting now I've
learned efforts in my time who I would
never react like that around they've you
like walk close by you can see them on
foot they don't mind at all
this cat is not friendly and as Tristan
describes though he says she's an angry
cat and he wasn't in the least bit
surprised when he saw her initiating the
aggression this morning now
unfortunately we might have to leave the
sighting at some stage because
unfortunately there are lots of people
trying to get into the sighting Safari
hard to those ears
tipped down mean precisely what they
would in a house cat they mean I'm not
happy I'm going to scratch and bite to
anything that makes me cross it now
she'll probably mark territory all the
way around kochava Street Java doesn't
look particularly panicked by the whole
affair and then I suspect what she'll do
is she might come charging back in there
because she came running up I don't
believe that and II didn't know who
Chavo was he I mean she's sitting in the
most obvious tree for miles but maybe
she just woke up stepped out of a
drainage line and saw her up here and
then thought oh I'll I'll show her and
it's that kind of noise that would have
brought the Lions in and that kind of
noise that would have bought in gharlane
I'm just gonna get on the radio quickly
I just have to find out how many people
are trying to get here how many stations
on standby for the sighting of each
other
because I fear me we are going to have
to vacate any stations on standby for
the sighting of kochava but if no one
answers their radios because they're not
listening that's really not my fault
sorry orbs say that again please
sorry about this everybody just enjoyed
the leopard
Andrew what's your position
okay we don't have to move just deities
in a while
okay thanks Andrew I'll move out as soon
as you get you he's still away away so
we don't have to leave just yet that's
correct news again if you are a new
viewer this is a game drive radio so
there are lots and lots of people around
here and so we just need to be very
sensitive to their needs and I'm using a
radio to talk to all these people um
sorry Julie I'm gonna have to ask your
question again the radio is in media
yeah I think the chances Julie are
absolutely that she could be more
aggressive to non-related females should
do Lou for example who is an unrelated
female I think would cop probably
slightly more of a warning than maybe
even more of a beating
then Paula Chavo got meted out or that
she meted out to each other today that
said I mean you know for tündi to have
made the physical contact that she did
he is not common for leopards bite on
another leopard it would be difficult to
see how it could have been that much
more aggressive
whoo great excitement here and the sabe
Santa
I see we're gonna take a moment to have
a bit of a breather and let's go just
down the road and that's amazing is
still a lot of activity around here not
with the Lions unfortunately they have
not moved I have heard one or two snores
coming from the Lions for a second I
thought Tristan was nearby the Lions are
just still resting and how far they they
moved during the course of the nut and
then early this morning but but yeah
they are not interested in moving at
this stage but I still think because it
is cooler there is a possibility that
they may get up and start moving around
so I'm gonna be very very patient and
sit with these resting lions but it's I
mean it's unbelievable to think that
maybe 200 meters to the east of where I
am now all those two leopards busy busy
having bit of a standoff I mean it is
amazing kochava and tandy and literally
200 meters yes okay Deaton I think that
links up to your question it yeah about
200 meters also I think within in that
vicinity so not fine if they if those
leopards start growling and making noise
then and then potentially these Lions
may then they may just be alerted and
and possibly move and investigates and
see what what is going on there what the
commotion is about at this stage we
haven't heard anything I can hear the
vehicles that are moving now and then
with those lipids but I haven't heard a
leopard sound or growl or anything like
that so and these Lions certainly have
not heard anything but if they do hear
it then possibly maybe them they may get
up and go and investigate
raising us all they're fortunate
actually to find them initially because
now with them lying so flat we wouldn't
have seen them in the long grass but we
saw that leg up in the air and that
large pole which just stood out for us
to be able to spot spot the lions lying
in the grass all right as I said I'm
gonna stay with these these lines even
though they're all resting but let's go
find out if there's any further activity
with the leopards no more activity said
did have a brief view of Tandy just a
little bit further east of where we are
now so basically to the front to the car
where she walked off and then she came
and peered around a bush from
malevolently
and then laid down but she's in the long
grass and I said I said we would like to
go for a walk around there now would you
he said no not very much you can see she
is completely or less asepsis could
easily have been going on for hours
you know she could have been running in
and out of the siting tündi that is and
shouting at the kochava for hours as
byron says their lions have turned
meters away which means I suspect undies
probably been looking at the chava for a
long time
Kangana has probably decided that hell
hath no fury like the proverbial scorned
there for this and so he's probably very
wisely keeping a distance from lions and
squabbling leopard Isis if I were him
I'd be far away from here as possible
Peter I don't know necessarily if a cab
makes a leopard more aggressive
certainly if she feels the cubs under
threat then yes absolutely but you know
would she feel that her cub was under
threat from kochava there are possibly
so possibly that is if if tandy didn't
have a young cub in the area perhaps she
would react with slightly less
irritation she certainly wouldn't be
particularly friendly about it though
but it is possible that she would be
slightly less aggressive see the claws
just sheathed over there
no I don't actually have to leave just
yet because over he's decided he's going
to leave so we can stay here for a
little bit longer see if we can see
where Tandy's come but it would be very
interested of course to get the leopard
experts testimony on what's happening
here well James it seems as though it's
just complete chaos and something that
we'll just have to wait and see exactly
what happens now you might be wondering
what is going on but because I was
trying to prove a point that's here it
is not very easy to find these lipids in
the grass particularly lipids the size
of Columba if they lie down it becomes
very very very difficult to find them
it's also the same situation up in Kenya
and one person who's had to deal with
that a lot
is Scotty Dyson well everyone I'm sure a
lot of you are very very happy to see
this cheetah its Kenya and she's got
lucky she's busy snacking on something
will tell you a little bit about that
later but more importantly we also got
lucky and yesterday we stumbled upon her
about 20 kilometers away from where she
was last seen about eight days ago we
stumbled upon this cheetah very close to
the Tanzanian border and I initially
wasn't sure who it was I was really
hoping at the beach Kenya the last time
she was seen only one of her five cups
appear to still be alive
once in position we could sell for
certain that it was her and once that
was established we took a closer look at
her nipples to see if there was any sign
of Cubs still nursing sadly it wasn't
the case confirming to us that she has
in fact lost all of them now as exciting
as as it is that we found her it's
obviously very sad that it seems like
she's lost all five of her cubs anyway
it's one of those things in nature and
at least she's got lucky she's got
herself this meal and after knowing
where she was yesterday in the evening
we came back here first thing in the
morning and got to witness this we got
off to an easy start finding her perched
up on a termite mound surveying the
plains for food it didn't take her long
and she descended with intent
she used the long grass as cover and
slowly crept forward before launching
her attack the Tommy tried its best to
avoid her dodging and weaving but she
was simply too fast and after a short
whistle had subdued her victim then she
wisely made sure no other predators had
seen the Hunts ensuring both her and her
meal were safe once contento threats
were nearby she dragged the killer short
distance before settling in for a feast
well that poor Tommy had absolutely no
idea Kenya was coming and a great
example of how stealthy a cheetah can be
when the grass is long they don't always
have to do very long chases at high
speeds I mean very happy that she has
managed to keep the skill to herself
because she hasn't managed to drag it
under a bush and I was concerned that
vultures were gonna give away her
position to some hyena that would steal
the skill from her but so far she's been
lucky and let's just hope that the next
few hours
she continues to snack on this we
certainly aren't going anywhere in case
any sneaky hyenas start to prowl about
and we don't want to miss a thing now
it's very sad to think that Kenya has
unfortunately lost her little ones it's
I was there trying to find them for the
eight days that she was missing and we
drove up and down and round and round
and round and I and thinking one day I
didn't even close to 200 kilometres just
around that sort of area trying to kind
of find her and spend time trying to see
you and an unfortunate problem was that
she just had so many predators around
there the one day we went walked in two
days that we went there we found three
different prides all unheard in sights
and around Hood in sight so she had a
real struggle with that I know there was
a method that even went into it the
insights a few weeks ago and so you know
it's for a cheetah in the Mara triangle
particularly it is incredibly difficult
she's got very few places to hide she's
got long grass in the particular area
that she was in which meant that there
is not very many prey animals so she had
to go very far for food and come back
again which means even if those cubs
exposed and even if she was there and
lions arrived she's just not equipped to
defend herself and her cubs from lions
she's quite quick Achilles Andre you're
gonna go into tree
she's quite quick and she can run away
obviously but the Cubs are still
helpless and defenseless at such a young
age and so if they get discovered in the
den like that
the chances are unfortunately that they
are not going to be able to survive
which is a very very big shame but
hopefully you know she'll bounce back
and she'll be able to find some way to
to Dinn that's you know after the
migration when things get a little bit
short to the gaskets with shorter maybe
a little more food that's all around
it's been a drama-filled week that's for
sure and today is just kind of the
capping on top and you know we're kind
of talking about all these things that
have been happening and you know today
is sort of a per to me of how difficult
it can be for our cats now in Louie's
Kenya moons early morning and then in
Swahili oh my actually which is the
local language in the Mara triangle and
so that's what it means and how she got
that name I'm not 100% sure to be honest
with you but I'll have to maybe try and
ask the cheetah man of Africa Scottie
Dyson himself and see what he thinks
about it at some point so I'll try and
get holler and see what if there was a
reason that she got named it anyway
we're going to carry on we're gonna try
and start having seen having to head out
of this area because it's getting dark
quite creepy now and so while we kind of
pace ourselves and try and start getting
a bit closer to home it sends you back
across to Ralph who I think it's full on
Chitra and I wonder if maybe somebody
else lurking on that side of the eight
hour area
well it's still a very very beautiful
scene unfolding here at chatter
waterhole some of the Egyptian geese
making a bit of a racket but well the
hippos are still doing what they do best
most of them sleeping a little bit of
movement especially from the little
youngsters may be getting a little bit
hungry and then you can see just in
between them there's a couple of the
blacksmith lapwings and the three-banded
clubbers here just on the water's edge
there's also the odd wagtail oh that's a
nice big mouth opening there that
youngster as well I'm sure they gonna be
getting a little bit irritated with all
the adults that are just snoozing away
as youngsters do and they want them to
get up and go moving and go feeding I
would imagine Tony I'm not quite sure if
I've seen or any of the guides have
actually seen any of these crocodiles
catching any fish or any of the prey
here next to the banks there's I know
that there's at least two big crocodiles
here I'm not seeing them today
we did see a monitor lizard a little bit
earlier but he disappeared down into a
little burrow and it's not the best of
days to see reptiles because it's rather
chilly relatively speaking for us out
here as I say the the reptiles they
don't really enjoy this cold weather
being ectothermic but I'm not quite sure
I don't know if James or Tristan or
anybody else has seen them eating any of
that now well there's a little bit of
action here with these baby hippos but
it seems like there's a whole lot more
action happening and just on over on
Juna well not right now but yes a lot
more action is happening
has happened on Juma I have seen those
crocodiles eating we saw them eating the
skin which think of an yalla or a bush
buck at one stage what happened to the
rest of the animal I think is pretty
self-explanatory from the last bits of
skin that they were in the water so
those crocodiles Defty do catch the odd
thing that comes down to drink I think
mainly they're eating fish though
piscivores crocodiles which other not
fazed by the incursions of her mother
very angry mother foul move the cheese
in has disappeared we haven't seen her
again we haven't tried to go and look at
her look firm under wait and see what
happens over here Andy yes we have named
Koh Chavez male cub his name is Dennis
it's a beautiful leopard name and we'll
be using it from today I have meant to
make that announcement earlier that the
chavez cubs name is Dennis the Internet
has now exploded no don't worry
everybody we have not called the cub
anything he does not have a name yet
we don't see him regularly enough if we
saw him again if we spent more time with
him definitely we would name but at this
stage now we have not named him we've
only seen him once would one kill I
think we may have seen him once more as
a little fellow but we haven't seen him
since the kill that we had on Torchwood
who was that probably about 6 weeks ago
now I think he's probably got quite a
lot bigger so Dennis who we will not
call Dennis has not been seen for some
time but I do ask that if and when we
nave him I ask very profoundly that we
don't choose a name as a gormless as she
do lu the termite mound nor hawker Marie
the chicken myths and both of those two
names and the two most ridiculous lipid
names I've ever heard in my life why
you'd call the most beautiful cat in
Africa termite mound and chicken
medicine is quite beyond me
our violin of course loves naming
animals it's his very favorite thing in
all the world he loves giving names not
only names but also titles to animals
and he's going to do that now for you
with your voges James yes well we've got
full Will and Thomas over here near
three of our males for woollen Thomas no
James James knows I do not enjoy the
naming animals well you know for the
purpose of again as I said for the
purpose of the show it's fantastic it's
great to have these characters and get
to get to follow them and and understand
the movements I just think is there's a
fine line that that we need to be
careful of anyway but I'm so glad that
there's been so much leper activity the
last few days and also the Lions we've
likely these males have come through but
you have had some other lions around a
few days ago we had and we actually had
another pride come through no surprising
me out of nowhere which was which was
really really interesting
a few days ago we would treat it with
another line citing at first we were
unsure of which pride it was after close
inspection we could make and this was
the that was the Taliban team pride that
you just saw that did arrive on Juma the
other day and they passed through quite
briefly well they spent the day here
which was nice so we've got to find them
very early in the morning and follow
them and again it was a nice cool
morning actually quite cold so that
we're very active during the morning
moving around they were they well they
clearly were hungry they were looking
for food they saw a number of different
antelope in the drainage lines and tried
to stalk but just unfortunately didn't
have any luck they did chase some Impala
and one or two in y'all at one stage but
they they weren't very very lucky in the
morning and they did end up settling
down
however we caught up with them again in
the afternoon
it was an overcast and cool start to the
sunset Safari we managed to find the
talimar cheap ride in the same area we
left them that morning they were very
affectionate towards each other and soon
began to get active and move scanning
the dense drainage line they were
clearly on the hunt again unfortunately
we were too exposed in the keyrings and
the ever alert Impala moved off very
swiftly there you could see we did
unfortunately find them again there that
afternoon and spent some time with him
again moving through the drainage lines
that thicker areas trying to look for
some potential food but then went out
onto the caring's and that just was
almost impossible its to open it was
still light all the Impala could see
them and as you could see from that
little clip the Impala alarm called they
followed the Lions they actually moved
towards them at one stage just so they
could keep an eye on them and as one or
two the younger lionesses ran off to
them the Impala just took off so the
Lions had no chance of hunting but I do
believe later that evening they did
cross out of jummah I mean they walked
right past camp which was amazing but
they crossed out of Jummah onto buffers
look and they did get something to eat
that evening I'm not sure what it was I
think it was a small kill possibly an
Impala but but I'm not not too sure but
they did apparently get something that
evening later that evening much later so
but wonderful to see the salamati pride
come through the five lionesses and the
two young males I've been been quite
fortunate this last week seeing two
different groups of lions that I have
not seen before the Tala Marti pride and
then the Evo cos who are still resting
now
I wonder if the other dark maned male
Jumma is having a good afternoon let's
go find out well I'm having a wonderful
afternoon a thoroughly enjoying being on
foot again it's one thing that I really
missed was actually being on foots and
walking in the bush that's good for the
salt and in the Mara you can't do it so
really really nice to kind of be out and
exploring again and sort of looking at
tracks and all these kind of things it's
been a bit tough one in terms of we
didn't see too many tracks and it was
kind of round around in circles and then
fine too much but you know sort of gave
it a bash me on our way home and you
never know if maybe something pops out
in front of us so we'll just keep going
and trying to see what there is
okay so Zandra has managed to plants
himself firmly inside of a tree which
took a bit of dancing those are very
good to step you did there Fred Astaire
would be very very impressed
in fact I wonder if you've been taking
lessons from Byron because Byron loves a
little dancing this afternoon he was
dancing wasn't easy Andre was all over
the place doing his little two steps and
singing him maybe he would like to sync
all of you because he was very vocal
this afternoon when we lived camp Byron
was good enough to give us a little sake
closer to a the tracks wave anyway we
need to kind of keep going through this
thicket but while we do that and
obviously we still looking out for
traction it's getting a little bit dark
and so the nocturnal animals are gonna
be starting to kind of come out and that
person was hoping in the Mara to find
some of the animals that were moving at
night when the rains had fallen
we're in the area searching for the
sausage tree pride and believe it or not
those scrapes in the mud actually really
care clues as to where they might be
yesterday evening Scott was here with
the sausage tree pride until a massive
thunderstorm sent him scurrying back to
camp we've returned to see what they got
up to and it looks as though they've
been very busy during the course of the
night so we have the tracks of them
slipping into the mud but it's not just
that there's some other tracks as well
so we can clearly see if we have a look
that there are lion tracks that are not
skidded or obscured there they are over
there and we can just see them as the
mud starts to dry but what's more
interesting in the reason for them
slipping and sliding all over the place
is off to the left a little bit over
there those are the tracks of a massive
buffalo bull and he clearly was in the
wrong place at the wrong time as the
sausage tree pride and took advantage of
the chaos of the storm to hunt him down
and try and catch him now the question
is where do these tracks lead and will
we find the sausages on a fresh Buffalo
kill vac we find ourselves over here not
having to work nearly as hard as Jamie
Patterson there in the masai mara we've
had to work in fact pretty unhard
this morning can one work unhard haven't
had to work very hard
easy day at the office harsh would be on
a Sunday afternoon now we've had no
update on where goo Chavez cubby is in
fact I haven't heard of a sighting of
the little male for some time but she
does spend a lot of time on the reserve
to the east of us where they don't do
much walking and certainly in fact it's
until this weekend it's been pretty sort
of bereft of much vehicle activity so
you know quite possibly stashed away
very safely in a drainage line over
there
my goodness it's not only cats out here
tonight now this is an absolutely
beautiful scene we've got the Sun going
down there with a lot of clouds around
making for beautiful colors and a lovely
young bull elephant just standing in
front for us now I think that elephants
for me are one of the most amazing
animals one of the large animals I must
say because enough I've actually spent
probably the most time with with
elephants out of all the big game
you know out of my years of following
them in the Namib Desert and I do really
enjoy being back here in their presence
and this being the first for me since
I've been away lovely to watch this
young bull seems he was just feeding on
a red bush water which is no mean feat
because it's very very hard would indeed
and I wouldn't like to be chewing on
that it would definitely break my teeth
very quickly so luckily that he's very
well adapted to grinding down hard would
like the complete him a pickle autumn
look at him he's very relaxed and as I
always say probably the best elephant to
watch is a bull elephant that's not in
must only very happy-go-lucky relaxed
and also quite in curious and
inquisitive very often approaching you
on foot but not in any menacing way only
just to come and see what you're all
about putting his ears out there little
bit that's definitely not to cool
himself down wafting his tail around
there's not many flies around either and
that's just probably in
habet it would be wafting the tail to
keep the flies away and wafting the ears
to keep themselves cool but well the
temperature is cool today and there's no
flies around so he's just probably doing
it from force of habit and putting the
ears out but then also just be to be
making himself look quite big and well
it looks like look at those eyes it
almost looks like he's a little bit
sleepy doesn't it and well he's not the
only sleepy animal out here it's been a
very busy week if you wanna do apologize
I'm also sleepy let's get back oh yeah
that's me pretending to be a play actor
sometimes I wish I was a play act
everybody and I'm sorry that you all
have to sort of live that dream
curiously with me well not for curiously
you have to witness it no progression of
any movement here we might take a little
turn around and see if we can't find
tündi after this while we do that it has
to go and take a look at what a male
leopard does after he's eaten himself
into a balloon
after a week of scavenging off his
mortal enemies the wild dogs 10 Ghana is
very fertile bursting return to southern
jr. on patrol his absence while feeding
has been prolonged and he was fearful he
established his presence lest some
interloper arrived and the Syrian youth
Timbers in need of another deep
astoundingly for a leopard this age his
condition seems to be improving rather
than declining and I'm not sure he's
ever looked heavier his sawing echoed
well into the darkness and in fact
workers were laughing camp
the tail I'm just trying to save
everybody we have found Tandy again
there she is and that's all vicious tail
tip of her started to go as we got close
so I stopped and now we're looking at
her endless spotty face through the
thorn bushes which are about as prickly
as her personality staring straight at
the back end of her daughter well much
as it must pain him with us sitting here
with our two leopards Tristan has
managed to find well something fairly
common really well this is about as
common as it gets James and you know
when you're scratching around trying to
find something at least is better than
nothing but it's still nice to be on
foot and just see you know impalas all
around you is actually an jana that's
going to come out fairly shortly for us
and kind of just expose itself on this
sort of crossing the road now there John
is it's gonna go across this also
beautiful too
patch of sky let's just lit up with the
sunset so we're trying to kind of hit
closer to home because it just starting
to get very dark and using your landing
parlors are actually very relaxed they
haven't moved very much at all they've
allowed us to get very close and you
know obviously if we were appear to like
something like a lipid or lines they
would have been shutting a long time ago
and so it just goes to show that they've
learned that some people walking around
here are no longer a threat to them you
know it would be interesting a few years
ago in you know hunting was probably in
this area a lot more than it is now
whether or not these guys would have had
a situation where they would have sort
of alarm called and ran or if they
would've just set still like they are
doing right now because they've really
fully aware that we are here at the
moment
right so we're going to try and walk
past them and try and kind of get out of
here and get a little bit closer to home
before it gets far too dark it's a
situation where we've got you know the
light fading very very quickly so we're
gonna have to do a little bit of a
hassle to get there but we were talking
a little bit earlier it's sort of
tracking in
the rewards that tracking can can bring
about and how important it is to be able
to recognize tracks and Jamie found out
just how important it is to be able to
see them and follow up on them we found
them we found them we tracked them down
and we found them and by the looks of
their head down yep there you go can
just see the tip of a buffalo horn we
were right in our interpretation of the
signs in the mud the sausage tree pride
I hope have caught themselves a buffalo
let's go and find out if it's them
and importantly let's go and find out
who's there
question remains they've been very very
split up over the last few days with the
young males here and the females there
we still haven't seen it
they're tiny the
we introduced you to not so long ago but
I'm really keeping my fingers crossed
that it's here
Celia mail one of the young males the
youngest of the me
rocks rocks
the trick when you drive in is to avoid
giant boulders
there we go and see kinky tail where he
will be there in one second to have a
chance to see
now
and only see two
it's definitely the sausages
well done Oh such a fresh kill and I'm
up way well done did you catch yourself
breakfast ah
kinky tails decided she didn't want to
be on camera and now he's going to oh no
he's not I was gonna say surely he's not
going to abandon their kill that quickly
from the tracks the whole pride was here
hopefully they're just taking a break
maybe having a drink after their hard
work of bringing down what looks like a
massive buffalo ball we're going to
stake out here sit and wait and see for
one of two things whether or not the
happy zebra clan decides to challenge
the sausages but more importantly
whether or not that little cocktail
sausage is brought for his first meal
now we've had a little bit of movement
from one of the male's starting to clean
himself he did stand up stretch it and
just change positions but who knows
possibly you may get some movement out
of all three of them now there has been
a lot of lion activity on safari live
especially the prides up in the Mara
pride but there there was another cub
that we wanted to show you of one of the
females seems to be a bit injured but
she at least had something to eat the
sausage tree pride did indeed manage to
keep the hyenas away from their buffalo
carcass and two days later they've moved
off leaving it to the vultures because
they are so incredibly full they were
full before they caught the Buffalo they
are now fitter to burst they have eaten
so much and they've chosen to lie
underneath the most impenetrable thicket
that they could possibly have chosen
that's surrounded by massive boulders
unfortunately this is at the best view
that we can possibly get the good news
is that all eight of the lions worth the
kill a couple of days ago so I suspect
they will all be here still but one of
them the missing lioness was not in the
best of conditions the massive Buffalo
kill served as a reunion for the sausage
tree pride and we rejoiced when we saw
the missing lioness who must have been
hiding somewhere and licking her wounds
painful punctures on her poor and nasty
scratches across her face tell a truly
distressing story but the discomforts
had not stopped her from gorging herself
she even managed to brave a relatively
short run on three legs appetite sated
she returned to the comfort of the shade
and her pride although that lioness is
limping really badly and she looks as
though she has some nasty puncture
wounds on her poor possibly from a bike
mark she does have a full belly and of
course she has kinky tail who is here
along with the rest of the pride to help
to keep her well-fed and lions are
resilient all animals out here are
resilient I think she's going to be
absolutely fine
unfortunately I'm afraid that the same
cannot be said for the little cub that
we saw a few weeks ago we've confirmed
that the female that's mating now on the
female that was mating earlier with
Brent is in fact the mother of that
small cub which is not a good sign at
all I think it's safe to say that the
harshness of the Mara the fact that that
lioness is a first-time mother and the
fact that that cub was all on its own I
don't think it managed to survive
unfortunate but as you can see in a
sausage tree pride are already busy at
creating the next generation of little
sausages well there is another
interesting clip and it is fascinating
HD TC with a line that gets injured as
long as that line is able to keep up
with the pride it will still feed and
I'm hoping and almost certain that that
right line will recover from the injury
and potentially be fine again now it
shows you just how nature works within
the pride and lions if they do fight to
injure themselves as long as the other
members of the Protestant and that line
gets food I've seen it before Lions will
recover very soon after quite a nasty
injury so that is really wonderful and
interesting to see with the sausage heap
right I'm not seeing them yet maybe one
day who knows
KB these Evo cos they'll probably only
get their full mains and about five or
six years old now I'm not entirely sure
of the age but I think judging by this
size they're probably around three or
four years old maybe a bit older than
that between four and five years older
think but you are the full Mane's
usually around five six years old
those Mane's really start filling out
and then by seven it's most likely a
full main carry so you KB I think that's
generally the age that they get those
four mains I think first if it's arrived
you're gonna try switch to infrared now
I was starting to lose quite a bit of
light all right so let's have a look and
see okay so little bit of movement there
has been one or two yarns but just
changing positions and nothing too
exciting just yet hopefully our patience
pays off all right let's head back to
James and find out how that lipids do
it could easily pay off you know they're
not far from here
nighttime is falling there might come
down here just to have a look see what's
going on now I think this is a rather
beautiful black-and-white image we're
looking at there it is of course shot in
infrared that is why it is black and
white and so we have arrived at the
artistic a piece of the show is the best
in the hangi gets to well play with his
artistic Gallic side as he said to me as
we drive around here he said please
excuse the accent ears Sebastian this is
Africa
it is wonderful Africa yes guy sorry I
was just waiting for your question sky
if I was gay Chava and obviously I'm not
I think I would climb down the tree and
slink away but she might be reticent to
do that because she knows Tandy will
chase her and she's definitely
Washington I just need to quickly get on
the radio for one second
affirmative go ahead
she looks pretty relaxed now in fact her
faces opposite you can grab some more
artistic shots of her beautiful face now
I know this is going to cause
consternation amongst the leopard fans
at the interweb but I think that kochava
is much prettier than her mummy what do
you think's if you agree good okay so
it'll be two of us who will be strung
out the dawn I think that is a
spectacular looking leopard take softer
adderdean fear me
all right for the first time ever Ralph
Kirsten with his highly excitable nature
is playing with the thermal camera let's
go and find out what he thinks about
that well we firstly having a look
through our infrared then you can see a
little bit of an obscured view of this
young bull elephant that we were
watching a bit earlier and he's still
stationary feeding nicely but what is
extremely interesting is going to be
when we have a look on the infrared
Fleur which is the thermal camera so now
we can see that that is all down to the
temperature that the animal is
exhibiting the blue being the larger
temperature and the higher the
temperature the rate of the color now
what is extremely interesting for me is
look at those ears they are almost you
know they're the coolest part of the
body and right down at the top of the
trunk seems to be the hottest part but
it is incredibly interesting to see all
the little hot points on the skin of
this elephant and how we can see him now
through the branches of the obscured
view that we have just with the naked
eye but wow that is it's amazing for me
to see this kind of image and what is
even more amazing is how cool
those ear flaps or and that just
indicates how the elephant sexually use
their ears as a real radiator and
cooling all that blood that's going
through there and that then obviously
leaves the ears heading towards the
brain and when it is very hot out here
in Africa that is an absolutely perfect
radiator now Tweety kid you say that
that would make an awesome t-shirt that
would definitely I think it's amazing
and elephants as I say one of if not my
favorite animal and well definitely the
animal that I have the biggest affinity
with because of the time I've spent with
him but this is a different angle
altogether and one that I have never
ever seen before and look at how he's
just using his trunk he's still feeding
on a lot of and wooden you know barky
pieces and branches which they tend to
do in winter and so it is absolutely
fascinating and thanks for joining me
and with this fascinating picture and
well as per usual I'm not the only one
with something fascinating James over to
you I told you he'd be deeply excited by
all of that technology well there he is
now we don't have a huge amount of time
left but we still have lots of
highlights from the Mara to show you so
let us moved from rosettes pasture spots
so everyone the good news is is that
Kenya did in fact manage to finish off
that a Thompson's gazelle kill without
being pestered by any hyenas and we left
her full bellied in the evening since
then however we've spent the last four
days searching and we haven't had any
luck now it's a tricky area to work for
a number of reasons the grass is very
very long and another major points is
that not too many other vehicles come
down into this corner of the Mara
triangle let me actually show you on a
map we are tucked away in the
southwestern corner of the triangle and
there's not too much going on down here
at the moment other than the fact that
Kenya has been seen here a few days ago
most of the other vehicles tend to spend
their time along the river now another
interesting thing while I do have the
map arts is that if we move back down to
the east over here where she used to
have a den sites around Myles Turner
Hill it's quite interesting to see how
far she's moved she's moved about 15
miles along the Tanzanian border to the
west to where we've lost had her in this
area now I'm hoping that she is in fact
still here in Kenya you can see this is
the border of Tanzania and she does
spend time in Tanzania we haven't been
following her too closely over the last
year so I don't know of her exact habits
but like I say let's hope she hasn't
crossed back south into Tanzania and
she's just lurking somewhere here in the
long grass we gonna keep searching and
I'm hoping before too long we will get
lucky again
sounds like Scott has been having a lot
of luck up in there in the Mara of late
which is wonderful hang on there was
some contact calls I'm hoping these
lines roar for us let's listen
yeah that just a soft call not quite an
ROI yet but possibly possibly we make it
a roar from these lines before the end
of the show how that would be ideal
Oh bless you one of the lines just
sneezed three sneezes come on little
contact calls think it's just that one
male on the right that is calling those
two still resting at least that one's
lifted lifted its head now if I can try
reposition for us just try reposition
again but I think stay with that self
because these lines are showing signs
that they possibly going to do something
interesting so I want you to miss it I'm
just gonna quickly go back this way and
I think whatever nice view of that one
line is got his head up
hey give me know if I'm gonna fall into
a hole please
here we go just Foreman Craig that's
gonna give it a little bit more space
here we go
Oh beautiful it's a lot better than we
can seen his lines very clearly not now
this would be amazing if they decided to
Roth right next to us isn't that
beautiful
all these lines I mean those mains
pretty decent and again I'm not too sure
how old they are but I would say they
close to five years old being around for
four or five years old four years old I
think but I'm not too sure maybe some of
you back home can let me know it was
wonderful seeing new lions for the first
time don't know where they come from
exactly I don't not sure where the
saveco pride comes from am i miss you
mean some way around funny bush perhaps
if I'm not mistaken uh I think I
remember a friend of mine saying that
they came from that side possibly
through thorny bush my nail eighty down
into this area there no males around
here at the moment
all right well I'm going to stay with
these lines again if they decide to do
something we'll let you know
but there's another character that we
would like you to meet we would like you
to meet another character we've had an
astounding afternoon and morning of two
leopards elephants we've had lions we've
had Tristan on foot which is enough to
cover at least four or five different
kinds of cats it's so entertaining but
this week making his world premiere on
the safari live show he is not a cat not
a dog
not even a carnivore but the world's
most boring hippopotamus we have a new
character on this week's Safari lives
scuba Steve is possibly the world's most
boring hippopotamus he spends every day
lying in exactly the same place so how
does an animal with the personality of a
cardboard box find himself included in
the lofty list of safari live characters
well Steve is no longer alone you see he
seems to have found while it is early
days yet the loss of waterhole has
transformed from a bachelor pad into a
love pond and we eagerly await further
romantic developments perhaps in eight
months two might even become three well
that's just a little bit of fun of
course we do play nasty jokes on well
behind the back of old scuba he doesn't
know that he's boring he thinks that
he's a perfectly normal hippopotamus
which of course he is he's a perfectly
normal hippopotamus but we are very much
enjoying the romance that's going on
there with Sarah and time will tell
whether they don't start their own
little pod there will eventually go
their separate ways we have of course
had a number of different hippo in that
water over the last few years sometimes
alone sometimes with girlfriends it may
will be
the same - but we go we're going to
pretend these are new characters to
Safari live and we're going to watch
very carefully as their little soap
opera unfolds in front of us just a
little bit of fun and I don't mean
anything nasty about scuba he is of
course a normal for bottom's why he
lives there and nowhere else given that
he is absolutely enormous I'm not really
sure because I don't think at his size
he would struggle to impose himself in a
waterhole such as chitra lastly look at
that picture
hmm now Baron said that those lions are
about 200 metres from us and I can't
hear them calling so let's see if you
wouldn't like to re estimate that James
yeah possibly
I'd like to reiterate that you are
probably a hundred and ninety eight
meters away because I can see your
leopard in the tree from here but
because they've got the spotlights on
the leopard at the moment let's see if
you can see in the distance so now
unfortunate because of the branches in
the way but we we can see the lights in
the spotlight so yeah you are that far
away James but yet these lines have not
cold but by the two heads up at the
moment
so are showing signs of getting more
active and hopefully moving around a
little bit
but you can see that Mohawk of hair that
is formed not so not quite the full main
yet I won't even gonna get a nothing
little gone there's been a bit of
yawning from these lines there we go
amazing there's really a wonderful
experience be able to sit with Lions
like us especially at night it's a it's
an eerie feeling a third one just
lifting its head now there we go
Digital tippet females with these males
currently but these males will
definitely meet up with females from
different prides now remember prides of
lions generally are made up of the
females and the yang stirs you will have
young males in that pride you may have a
dominant male that stays within the
pride but what's happened for many years
now in the sabi sands in this area
especially we've had coalitions of males
so three four five six males sometimes
that tend to stick together
and move around increasing their
territory size meeting up with females
from different prides mating with them
and having offspring so that's what
these males will potentially do and
possibly are doing already they will at
some point challenge other males for
territory extend and expand their
territory there we go come on he looks
like he wants to
it's useless teasing sound of lions
wanting to roar
but with all three heads up the chances
of it happening are a lot better
all right again I'm going to wait until
the very end
let's go to Ralph he's got a tiny
nocturnal creature to show you well
here's one of our very common night time
creatures the little Cape scrub here and
well he's just looking at us in there in
the darkness here and well I've just
returned from my leave and it's been an
absolutely wonderful week it seems out
here in the bush in the juma Traverse of
the greater Kruger National Park and
we've got a little rep to show you of
exactly what happened with all the cats
[Music]
in Ghana the Juke came across on Tajima
from tortured in the southeastern corner
Tandi was present in the central parts
later moving southwards the talam Archie
pride made an unexpected appearance near
the juma camp while Colombo was in a
normal abode to the east the Avoca males
caused the commotion this morning
showing up with all of Tandy cassava and
tin ghana so as I said it seems to be an
absolutely blockbuster week here on on
the juma and cheetah and Torchwood
region but mainly on Juma and that's why
I always say in the bush always expect
the unexpected
because before I left it was actually
relatively quiet in terms of the
leopards and lions movement but in the
last week and before that as well it
seems like the bushes are absolutely
exploited with different sightings so
it's always a different perspective
every single day you can expect
something new
happen so well I'm just gonna keep on
looking and tomorrow morning exactly the
same well James back over to you
little Lepidus in the tree beautiful as
she is slinky feline is now snoozing
relaxedly I think tündi will probably
leave her alone but perhaps once we've
all departed and things have quieted
down go Charles slink down the tree and
disappear into the darkness of Tandy
we'll turn around head north back to
Columba we certainly found Columba this
morning as Justin showed you a little
bit earlier and sensual Tandy we'll go
back that way once user well calm down
and alert aloud this territorial dispute
to dissipate
well it's an interesting interesting
comment change which would you say
kochava looks like the perfect blend of
Tandy and boola boola we're pretty sure
is equal Chavez father if I'm not much
mistaken
now I'm not mistaken that is true and I
you know many people can see and
recognize faces and animals better than
I can
I don't see him pull it in her face
James but I'm not saying that it isn't
there I certainly don't see her mother's
face I must say I think she's got a much
less I've used this term before and I
use it advisedly their short nose should
we say pop poke bug nose she's got a
much longer nose in her mum's she also
seems to have Edie I'm sure this isn't
correct but she seems to have fewer
wrinkles on her face her mother does
Tandi and shadow who were sisters
gorillas firstborn they looked very
similar shadow now passed on but Tandy
had a very similar look to her I could
definitely see the resemblance there but
in bulla who at one stage was my
favorite leopard I can't see in this cat
but that's probably me and James Richard
of course can identify a leopard from
well a slight visual of one spot on the
hind left foot which is a very
impressive so I'm going to defer to his
better judgment and recognition skills
now sorry Kirsten I think I missed a
meal we going to get back to Byron here
are we going to stay here and wait and
see we can hear the Lions calling I see
right it will go back to the lines if
they call but at the moment they are
what Byron loves to call fat cat he
actually hates to call them Flast cat I
don't know why that is so amazing Burns
has become quite a traditionalist in his
old age old age of course he's earned a
33 I think that is just a gorgeous shot
what a wonderful day it's been many of
you saying what a wonderful Drive and
thank you for that but what a wonderful
day and tomorrow of course we're at it
again Monday morning nothing stops art
here nothing has a break and so neither
do we
and therefore neither do you so 6:30
tomorrow in the morning until 8:30 we
are still doing drone tests between 5:30
and 6:30 and if we do happen to come
across the cat using the thermal drone
we will definitely go live between 5:30
and 6:30 on Facebook so just keep an eye
out for that
in the meantime we'll be live from 6:30
to 8:30 in the morning so that's very
exciting Sydney we'll have a second go
tomorrow thank you all of you for
welcoming him today and he'll be on
Drive again tomorrow along with the
byron and Ralph I believe thank you very
much for joining us all today it's been
naturally a joy and a pleasure to share
the highlights of the week I really love
these Safari lives weekly shows and I
hope they will become an institution
until tomorrow stay safe and happy
wherever you happen to be in the world
and we'll see you as the dawn breaks in
Africa